ils ont karine tu reviens jaune tu veux
celui là ah tiens bonjour comment allez
vous ça c'est curieux il y en a parmi
vous que je connais très bien et
d'autres que j'ai encore jamais vu ça
c'est vraiment formidable d'avoir autant
de nouveaux amis le même jour
je suis vraiment très content de vous
voir vous avez vu les enfants
nous avons de nouveaux amis à les jouer
maintenant
ce qui m'étonne quand même c'est que
d'habitude je suis toujours prévenues
par une lettre officielle
quand de nouveaux arrivants viennent
dans l'île aux enfants mais ça fait rien
le principal c'est que vous soyez tous
là comme parmi vous il ya beaucoup de
nouveaux venus
je vais vous faire faire le tour du
jardin et je suis certain que tous ceux
qui connaissent déjà l'île aux enfants
seront d'accord avec moi
ah au fait moi je m'appelle françois je
suis le marchand de ballons du jardin
qui se trouve au centre de l'île aux
enfants
quand j'ai fini de vendre mes ballons et
bien j'en profite pour lire et étudier
parce que mon rêve ce serait de devenir
un vrai savant très savants
ils ont karine s'il y eu d'accord je te
donnerai tombe à l'envers tout à l'heure
parce que je vais emmener nos ou nouveau
à nous voir jouer
d'accord va jouer mais je les nie la
nuit là ni là ni la maison julie qu'est
ce que j'ai pu faire de ce couvercle aux
excuses - françois mais j'ai pas le
temps de parler le couvercle de bocal de
caramel a disparu la veille à 3 minutes
dans les mains il fait comme va
l'utiliser julie regarde un peu mieux
son bocal par exemple le couvercle et
etc oui j'avais plus cherché longtemps
décidé vaud je suis toujours aussi
discrète c'est pas grave si tu changes
et l'île aux enfants ne serait plus tout
à fait la même et puis comme ça nous
nouveaux amis auront tout de suite
appris à connaître nous nouveaux amis
regarde là bas
par exemple mais c'est vrai il y en a
beaucoup que je connais déjà très bien
il y en a beaucoup que je n'ai jamais eu
c'est fantastique on va pouvoir s'amuser
mille fois plus témoin pour que tu ne
m'avait pas prévenu tu toujours au
courant qu'en cas de nouveaux arrivants
dans l'île en justement j'ai pas ce qui
s'est passé fait pas reçu la lettre
officielle le secteur là peut-être
oublié ça m'étonnerait il fait très
sérieusement son travail
ouais c'est vrai tu as raison c'est pas
grave tout ça ça n'a aucune importance
vite avec cette histoire de lettre
j'avais complètement oublié de vous
présenter julie julie avec son amie
sabrina qui vient la remplacer de temps
en temps à la plus jolie boutique de
l'île aux enfants
elle vend de tout démontrons car à même
la guimauve du chocolat et chewing-gum
des bateaux des chouettes des balles de
la limonade de la glace en fin de toutes
ses formidables et françois casimir va
arriver où le faire l'inventaire de ma
boutique
tu ferais mieux de présenter à nos
nouveaux amis pour qu'ils soient pas
trop effrayer
tu crois enfin tous ceux qui connaissent
déjà casimir savent très bien qu'ils
seraient pas peur n'est ce pas enfin je
vais quand même vous présentez casimir
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas et bien
casimir tenez dont vous entendez
justement là la douce et harmonieuse
voix casimir est le descendant d'une
très vieille famille de monstres un de
ses ancêtres avaient réussi pendant
l'ère secondaire a chassé de l'île aux
enfants les féroces tyrannosaure qui
faisait régner la terreur et pour ça le
grand père casimir eu c'est à dire
l'ancêtre de casimir avait réussi à
ridiculiser sans violence le chef des
tyrannosaures en prouvant qu'il était
encore plus bête que méchant et depuis
ce jour dans l'île aux enfants les
casimir us ont vécu heureux et le plus
gentil d'entre eux c'est quasi 1000
d'ailleurs je l'appelle je vais vous le
présenter
casimir casimir vient pas rivoire
casimir françois oui je m'appelle
toujours un criant et ça me fait peur et
qui me fait sursauter
j'en ai assez alors mais toi en garde
défend thouars je vais t'écraser comme
une puce
bravo bravo bravo très bien casimir et
moi justement qui venait de venir à nos
nouveaux amis que tu étais très gentil
nous nous avons des nouveaux amis oui
regardez les eaux mais il ya des enfants
que je ne connais pas mais n'est pas
permis d pas peur quasi mairie sont très
gentils et vimy tu pourrais souhaiter la
bienvenue à nos amis en chantant sa
chanson
ah ça c'est une bonne idée tu crois que
ça va leur faire plaisir
certainement bon ben alors on y va
[Musique]
habitude la chanson est un peu
d'imagination je vous emmène
le prix
[Musique]
zoomer compris
je sois y est terrorisée je suis le
monstre qui périt
je m'appelle
couleur orange
gagnon
si l'on manie maladroit
et pour moi
baj
et de la musique
je suis né et smalling amis
la glace au sens soit c'est mon droit
c'est mon droit avec une chanson
un petit magie danse
je vous emmène dans notre it is mon pays
du bonheur tranquille
[Musique]
c
me rencontrer un soyez pas terrorisé
je suis le monstre qui fait rire
[Musique]
j'ai une magie
une idée
je mange eux
l'oubli pour les gars mais je danse je
[Musique]
cogne
si mes mains
roy a vécu tout chansons
à 2
imagination
priscilla
m
[Musique]
ils couverts
soyez pas des mots ici
je suis le bon sens qui fait rire
[Musique]
casini
[Applaudissements]
bonjour lui dit bonjour françois larribe
d'un facteur voilà ils sont bien arrivés
oui quand j'ai vu la lettre officielle
ce matin j'ai été bien content pour vous
pendant un an la lettre officielle
j regard ce n'est pas croyable enfin je
je relise un casino puisqu'il venait au
jardin à casimir veille il a dû la
remettre dans la boîte aux lettres à
nous comme la dernière fois
non parce que justement je vérifier
alors qu'est ce qu'ils en effet le puis
ça me serait lui n'en est pour sûr vous
avez raison ils tombent d'accord
quasiment y avoir désigné
qu'as tu fait de la lettre que je te
donnais pour françois la lettre
quel angle alec oui je l' ai apporté tu
m'as donné la lettre maintenant je l' ai
apporté mais comme tu n'étais pas là
alors j'ai eu peur qu'on la volt oui
alors je les biens cachés dans les
ballons voilà
casini